digamos que tengo un objeto en
movimiento vamos a ponernos aquí un
objeto que está moviéndose y el el
movimiento que describe es una
trayectoria circular que más o menos
esta es una trayectoria circular que
gira alrededor de un centro muy bien
entonces tenemos este movimiento y
estamos pensando que el movimiento es
antihorario es decir en contra del
movimiento de las manecillas del reloj
ahora lo que quiero que hagamos en este
vídeo es pensar qué tan rápido gira
digamos su órbita este este objeto
alrededor de su centro y cómo es que
esto se relaciona con su velocidad muy
bien entonces para para fines de este
vídeo vamos a suponer que este objeto
gira a cinco revoluciones
5 revoluciones
por segundo
muy bien son cinco revoluciones por
segundo que estamos diciendo con cinco
revoluciones por segundo pues si tú
piensas en este radio ok entonces
estamos pensando que este objeto da le
da cinco vueltas después por cada
segundo es decir pasa un segundo y da
uno dos tres cuatro cinco vueltas a este
a este recorrido muy bien ahora bien
esto por supuesto no es algo que se
utilice mucho ya que las unidades
normales o digamos convencionales que se
utilizan para este tipo de digamos de
velocidad es el de los radiales por
segundo por segundo entonces tenemos que
cambiar las revoluciones por radiales es
decir hacer una conversión de unidades
entonces si pensamos en cuánto cuántos
radiales dad después de una vuelta pues
estos son dos y ryan es verdad ya lo
hemos hoy así a lo mejor esto no tiene
mucho sentido para ti te recomiendo que
veas vídeos de este tema
quiere decir que por cada revolución es
decir por cada vuelta tenemos dos pi
radian es verdad por cada revolución muy
bien entonces esto que a que es igual
vamos a ver tenemos 5 por 2 y estos son
10 pi y luego las revoluciones se
cancelan con las revoluciones y lo que
nos queda son radiales radiales sobre
segundo verdad radiales sobre segundo y
esto por supuesto tiene sentido verdad
si damos dos pirra dian es por cada
vuelta y son cinco pues tenemos los
pitidos p2p los pi 25 veces y eso nos da
10 radiales por cada segundo porque por
cada segundo de cinco vueltas muy bien
estas dos miden esencialmente lo mismo
es qué tan rápido órbita alrededor del
centro ok ya esto es o algo por el
estilo es a lo que vamos a conocer como
velocidad angular y quiero hacer una
anotación aquí porque esto de aquí es lo
que podríamos tratar de entender como
velocidad angular pero no es exactamente
lo que sí sabemos es que por ejemplo
esto es este es la rapidez es la rapidez
y la rapidez la vamos a denotar con la
letra griega o mega minúscula ok pero en
realidad esto no es la no es una
cantidad vectorial verdad porque la
velocidad es una cantidad vectorial lo
que ocurre es que aquí digamos la
velocidad o el vector velocidad es un
vector que digamos que sale de el papel
de la hoja digamos no se ve como por
aquí afuera verdad que es digamos que se
sale de esta hoja verdad eso sí el
movimiento es antihorario si el
movimiento fuera en dirección de las
manecillas del reloj ese vector digamos
atravesaría la hoja de papel y bueno no
vamos a hablar mucho de esta
justificación matemática de digamos en
cursos básicos de física o similares a
lo que tenemos aquí podríamos en
interpretar esto como la
angular muy bien esta es una cantidad
que es un pseudo vector no no vamos a
meternos mucho en eso solo vamos a decir
que esta velocidad angular o digamos
rapidez o mega es el cambio del ángulo
dividido entre el cambio del tiempo
verdad aquí es cuánto cuánto cambio el
de ángulo pues son 10 pi por el cambio
del tiempo que es por segundo verdad y
que si tú quieres verlo ya utilizando
cálculo diferencial si a lo mejor ya
tienes más preparación en ello pues uno
puede pensar que la velocidad
instantánea del ángulo con respecto al
tiempo pues simplemente es la derivada
del ángulo justo con respecto al tiempo
muy bien entonces ahora para para ver
cómo se relaciona esto con lo que es la
rapidez del objeto pensemos en que esta
distancia de aquí es el radio aunque
este es el radio del círculo que recorre
este este objeto entonces quiere decir
que la circunferencia que recorre
y de hecho vamos a ponerle que este
radio este radio vamos a ponerlo aquí
este radio pues se mide en metros verdad
ya de una vez para trabajar con las
unidades son metros entonces la
circunferencia es decir el diámetro
perdón es el el perímetro de esta
circunferencia es 2 p r verdad así es
cómo calculamos la circunferencia
entonces vamos a tratar de pensar cómo
relacionar todo esto que hemos estado
trabajando con la rapidez instante o la
rapidez que lleva nuestro objeto muy
bien entonces nosotros sabemos si lo
ponemos de esta forma que la velocidad
la velocidad angular
es igual a digamos omega radian es
sus unidades son radiales sobre segundo
muy bien y siempre vamos a tratar de
trabajar con radiales porque es digamos
las unidades convencionales ok es es
cómo se adopta la convención
ahora bien cuántas cuantas revoluciones
o cuántas vueltas tenemos por cada
radian o más bien cada dos y radiant es
2 y radiales
tenemos una vuelta o una revolución
verdad entonces si nosotros efectuamos
esto simplemente se cancelan los
radiales y nos quedan omega entre dos
revoluciones sobre segundo verdad sobre
vamos a completarlo sobre segundo ahora
bien nosotros queremos ver cómo se
relaciona con la rapidez así que vamos a
déjenme copiar esto mega entre dos pi
revoluciones sobre segundo
nosotros podríamos ver cuántos metros
tenemos por cada vuelta es decir
nosotros tenemos dos p r metros sobre o
es decir por cada revolución por cada
vuelta verdad entonces de esta forma lo
que estamos consiguiendo es que quitamos
las revoluciones y nos quedamos con
omega de hecho podemos cancelar también
el 2 picón el 2 pinos que da omega por
el omega por ere metros metros sobre
segundo verdad y aquí es lo que ya
tenemos como una rapidez verdad ya
tenemos en las unidades de la rapidez
que son metros sobre segundo entonces a
esto de aquí déjenme de notarlo con v
con b esto es algo que le vamos a
conocer como rapidez y ojo no le estoy
poniendo un una flechita porque esto no
es un vector esto es digamos esto es un
número verdad entonces esto de aquí es
lo que vamos a conocer como rapidez y de
hecho pues podemos ponerlo así verdad
que la rapidez es igual a un mega que es
la velocidad angular por eres verdad y
esto no es un vector en realidad la
velocidad angular recuerden que es un
vector que sale de la hoja o la traviesa
verdad pero aquí estamos pensando en la
norma de ese vector es más si lo ponemos
en palabras lo que tendremos es que la
rapidez la rapidez es igual a la
velocidad angular velocidad
angular
y por supuesto nuevamente remarcó esto
no es un vector lo estamos pensando como
la magnitud de la velocidad angular del
vector velocidad muy bien y multiplicado
por el radio del movimiento por el radio
ok y de hecho la formulita si de hecho
si nosotros quisiéramos conocer la
velocidad angular sabiendo la rapidez y
el radio pues simplemente tendremos
dividiendo de ambos lados entre el radio
si dividimos entre el radio pues nos
queda que la velocidad angular es la
rapidez entre el radio y como siempre
estas fórmulas pueden ser muy útiles
para resolver problemas pero al menos
espero que te hayan sido interesantes
sobre todo para ver cómo se relaciona
con el tema